did you know that german chancellor olaf
schultz has been four weeks lying about
everything regarding german support for
ukraine cool me neither here's a great
threat about it by thomas t tyner linked
below which i'm now going to signal
boost legend below was mightily behind
at the end of february germany's defense
industry sends schultz a long list of
all available weapons schultz doesn't
share the list with ukraine schultz says
that there are no more weapons left in
germany to give to ukraine
germany's defense industry leaks the
list to ukraine's ambassador schultz
says that the weapons on the list don't
work the defense industry denies this
and leaks the list to the press schultz
states that the ukrainians can't master
the weapons in the available time german
defense experts tell the german press
that the ukrainians can master weapons
in 2-3 weeks schultz says that the
weapons are needed by nato and nato must
approve of their transfer nato officials
and german generals deny this
schultz says that no other nato eu ally
is delivering heavy weapons to ukraine
the us uk australia poland czechia
slovakia romania turkey italy finland
denmark romania netherlands etc
published the lists of heavy weapons
they delivered to ukraine
under pressure schultz announces 2
billion euros for ukraine's military
german parliamentarians find out that
it's really just 1 billion which won't
be available for another 2-3 months and
then schultz can veto or delay
indefinitely every item ukraine wants to
buy
the us france poland romania japan the
uk and italy plus the heads of eu and
nato spend an afternoon trying to talk
sense into shorts
schulz makes a statement and says that
ukraine can have the 1 billion now and
order whatever it wants from the list
ukraine's ambassador says that schultz
removed all the items ukraine actually
wants from the list before giving it to
ukraine and what remains on the list is
just a fraction of the 1 billion so in a
nutshell never again might ruin except
when the price is right